que l'on appelle les groom le premier
groom juste derrière le meneur et le
navigateur alors que là bon le
l'attelage a dû s'arrêter hein euh ça
fait 12 m voilà 12 m de long c'est c'est
vraiment très très long quand on doit
passer dans des portes très étroites
donc deux navigateurs derrière le meneur
de de groom pardon un navigateur qui va
donc donner les indications au meneur et
derrière un un autre Grom plus lourd qui
lui est chargé de décaler la voiture
dans les obstacles quand ça passe trop
près on va revenir un peu plus tard en
direct au marathon 16000 personnes sont
présentes sur ce marathon une ambiance
très populaire un peu moins feuté que
sur le dressage hier où on croisait
beaucoup d'experts mais aussi quelques
néophites qui ont semblé prendre
beaucoup de plaisir en assistant à ce
spectacle reportage de Pierre Marie et
de cy
donchal
la plume au vent la plume au vent voilà
elle est là-bas une
Américaine surtout pas d'applaudissement
quand l'attelage entre sur la piste dans
l'épreuve de dressage le silence est
requis c'est comme au tennis on n pas le
droit de rentrer tant que les joueurs
sont dans l'arène peut-être que les
chevaux faut pas on sa pas pas milieu
doivent pas entendre grandchose je crois
pas alors à de pouvoir applaudir Jean et
Jean Yve il vont de leur
comment
[Rires]
for for
chevaux l'entrée le salut le TR le
virage tout est codifié tout est noté
reste encore à pouvoir
décoder la prière fois que j'envoie des
visus sur place
c'est
pointu une main de main tout est dans
le c'est du travail de précision
bon du beau
sport allez bien en
[Musique]
ligne c'est
flu vous finissez par avoir le coup
d'œil bah on apprend vite on apprend ah
oui mais bon on est des gars de la
nature on est des gars de l'agriculture
alors on a la f sur
[Musique]
elle a l'air d'avoir des bonnes notes
madame tu as vu madame Riley meer elle
va faire un
malheur par contre ce que je comprends
pas c'est
le les notes ici c'est pas les mêmes
qu'à la fin là j'ai pas compris encore
pourquoi peut-être que j'arriverai à
comprendre un
jour mais oui oui oui on finit toujours
par comprendre les règles du dressage on
va retourner sur le marathon avec le
passage du Normand Fabrice Martin oui
c'est l'homme de de canibberville
Fabrice Martin qui a fait un une de ses
meilleures performances en dressage hier
euh on le voit là dans l'obstacle je
crois que c'est la montre Rolex voilà
c'est ça c'est l'obstacle numéro 4 alors
bien sûr en forme de montre un un
labyrinthe de porte extrêmement
compliqué vous le voyez là avec des des
entrées très serrées alors à chaque
porte vous avez une lettre rouge une
lettre blanche la lettre rouge doit
toujours être à droite et dans ces
obstacles et bien le chrono se déclenche
à l'entrée de de de l'obstacle et on
l'arrête en sortie alors on voit qu'il
prend pas mal de précautions hein
Fabrice Martin dans cet obstacle parce
que si les chevaux sont bloqués c'est
très compliqué très compliqué vous voyez
là ça se ça se bloque entre les chevaux
de tête de volet et les timonniers c'est
très compliqué de reculer et alors il y
a beaucoup de choses qui passent par la
voie et le meneur dispose de deux guides
pour conduire ces quatre chevaux et je
peux vous dire qu'il faut être ultra
ultra concentré on voit le travail des
mains là et on voit les chevaux de de
volet qui ont les oreilles en avant qui
sont très très concentrés tis que ch de
l'arrière les timonniers ont les
oreilles qui qui
se remettent vers l'arrière vers la voix
du menendra des nouvelles de Fabrice
Martin on va prendre des nouvelles un
peu plus tard à tout à l'heure Corine
alors pour l'instant place à la voltige
au carton plein pour la France médaille
d'or et d'argent en individuel homme
médaille de bronze par équipe ils sont
tous là on les a montré au début de
l'émission fatigués mais heureux il faut
dire quelle journée quelle journée bravo
à vous ça a commencé par ce podium en
individuel on va voir les images et la
marseillaise qui a retenti dans le
zénite de camp l'or pour Jacques Ferrari
et l'argent pour Nicolas and beaucoup
d'émotion quelle joie il faut dire que
l'un et l'autre nous avait offert du
très grand spectacle on va revenir sur
vos presses magnifiques d'abord
peut-être la votre Jacques Ferrari on va
vivre un peu ce podium et puis tout de
suite on va on va regarder cette cette
reprise ce passage hier qui était
vraiment magnifique et on va le le
commenter ensemble on avait l'impression
hier en regardant ça que rien rien ne
pouvait vous
arrêter disons que c'était un peu un peu
particulier parce que il y avait
beaucoup d'émotions avant même de
rentrer en piste avec François avec le
cheval avec tout le staff qui était
derrière François votre longeur franis
monur excusez-moi avec le staff qui
était derrière effectivement je suis
rentré en piste on était tous un petit
peu transcendés
ouais un petit peu atteint touché par
par beaucoup d'émotion parce que c'était
aussi une de nos de nos dernières
performance ensemble en individuel et
donc du coup on savait que voilà fallait
donner fallait vivre vraiment ce moment
dans le présentait pas se procheter
essayer de des compo sur sur des sur du
calcul la notation avoir peur deut juste
donner qu à fond et pens à rien d'autre
donc rentrer dans dans ce processus
assez difficile et puis un moment on a
laissé faire et en restant hyper
vigilant et concentré ben les choses
sont venues et les émotions nous ont un
peu submergé et ça s'est fait un peu un
peu tout seul poivre vert pe peut-être
passer le micro à François timou votre
longeur poivre vert a été le cheval a
été impeccable poivre vert il a fait
quatre magnifiques passages voilà c'est
un cheval que qu'on a depuis 2009 le 29
aût 2009 on a on a fait programmer cette
échéance est-ce que c'est vraiment un
travail à TR faut bien que les gens
comprennent
le cheval et vous le long sur la piste
oui sur la piste oui en coulisse il y a
énormément de monde il y a un staff des
vidolair on est aujourd'hui le
représentant il y a énormément de monde
des marischa des groom des vétérinaires
un préparateur des chevaux s enfin voilà
il y a vraiment un travail collectif
c'est combien d'heures d'entraînement
par semaine pour arriver à ce niveau-là
il est monté 1 he et de par jour deux
fois une travail travail le matin et
puis une petite balade l'après-midi il
voltige à peu près deux fois par semaine
alors on va s'adresser maintenant à
Nicolas Andr m d'argent hier soir une
petite déception Nicolas andrani parce
que vous avez fait une petite faute
effectivement une petite faute mais la
déception parcours la déception a été
vite digérée parce que voilà c'est c'est
la seule qui me manquait pour compléter
mon tableau de chasse il y a il y a 4
ans c'était c'était en bronze que que
j'avais été récompensé il y a 2 ans
c'était c'était en or et et voilà et je
suis non je su je suis très heureux
parce que c'est un Français voilà la
petite faute et et sur sur cet élément
effectivement sur la den mais là où je
suis très content c'est qu'après la la
petite faute que ce soit malongeuse qui
qui est juste derrière moi Marina avec
qui vous travaillez depuis 23 ans vous
avez elle vous a connu vous aviez 6 ans
c'est ça c'est ça je je suis arrivé au
club B Deo à à 6 ans et et puis depuis
on on bosse toujours ensemble avec
Marina et non là où je suis très content
c'est que effectivement la faute est
arrivée asse tôt dans le dans le
programme et malgré ça j'ai j'ai déroulé
après un programme à la perfection et
j'ai pu garder cette seconde place et là
où je vous disais que je suis je suis
ravi c'est que finalement la la
Marseillaise a quand même retenti ou et
puis de toute façon vous travaillez
ensemble dans votre compagnie Noroc qui
est créée depuis un an vous vous
travaillez ensemble et vous donnez des
des spectacles et puis c'est un ami qui
décroche finalement ouou c'est c'est un
ami voilà c'est c'était un concurrent
pendant une minute mais à côté de ça
c'est c'est un ami
effectivement on bosse effectivement à
côté ensemble aussi donc c'est c'est que
du bonheur pour la France et pour la
voltige alors vite éipe avec Robin on va
demander au plus jeune Robin 13 la
médaille de bronze hier soir là aussi de
l'ambiance on va peut-être voir le
podium pant qu'on parle vous allez être
une star dans votre collège Robin oui il
y a beaucoup de fill dans la classe
qui orograph des ches comme ça David
vous êtes
l'entraîneur le sélectionneur national
de cette équipe de France de vol
mais pouviez pas arêver mieux ouais
difficilement c'est vrai qu'on a vécu
une journée assez assez fabuleuse hier
on a vraiment la chance d'avoir une une
très belle équipe de France avec des de
beaux athlètes des longeurs qui sont qui
ont été extraordinaires toute cette
semaine et puis puis des chevaux
français je pense qu'il faut qu'on qu'on
le soulligne parce que et la french
touch on a beaucoup parlé de la French
Touch pendant ces jeux cette façon
d'interpréter finalement on est au-delà
du sport on est dans dans de l'art
finalement ouais on a on attache une
grande importance depuis déjà pas mal
d'années à C cet aspect artistique
c'estàdire qu'audelà de l'aspect
technique et ça se VO conna pas beaucoup
en vol ça se voit ouais souv les G la
discipline quoi on a voulu s'extraire un
petit peu de la du côté un peu
germanique avait initialement la
discipline pour en donner peut-être un
côté un peu plus latin et on travaille
ça avec Romain Bernard depuis une
dizaine d'années notre chorégraphe qui
est en plus un ami de des vour également
et qui n produit du travail assez
fabuleux ben bravo à vous nous avez
donné beaucoup d'émotion bravo bravo
bravo merci
beaucoup ce weekend ou on attend aussi
avec impatience la suite des épreuves de
CSO ça commence dans quelques minutes
maintenant au stade
d'Ornano tout est possible toutes les
cartes peuvent être rebatttues mais une
chose est sûre pour l'instant la France
s'en sort bien une médaille d'argent par
équipe et une folle semaine on fait le
bilan de tout ça avec Corine
burosa
la France en argent deuxè du classement
par équipe en saut d'obstacle après une
finale à
rebondissement les parcours sans faute
de Kevin Stot et pénéope le préau
Patrice de laavau et son étalon Orient
Express impiégeable depuis le début de
la compétition n'ont pas droit à
l'erreur pour espérer devenir champion
du monde mais dès le début du parcours
le Normand commet la faute de trop sur
ce
vertical la France est seconde derrière
les Pays-Bas et devant les
États-Unis Méda par équipe c'est
vraiment le travail de toute
l'équipe on a raté certains parcours
d'autres ont réussi les choses sont
interchangé donc je pense que pour en
profiter on en profite tous ensemble
avec notre public c'est vrai que je
pense qu'elle a une superbe saveur cette
cette médaille
d'argent tout a commencé mardi par
l'épreuve de vitesse un parcours moins
haut à 1,50 mais dont le profil de
certains obstacles pose de sérieux
problèmes au concurrents et
particulièrement cette falaise des
trotas qui effrait les chevaux il en
fallait plus pour arrêter Patrice del
laavau et son fidèle Orient Express 2e
au classement provisoire après cette
épreuve Pénélope le prévau et sa jeune
jument Flora de Mariposa termine à la 6e
place ma Gent est est fantastique et
très rapide et elle a que 9 ans c'est
vrai effectivement on n pas l'expérience
toutes les deux des championnats mais
c'était ouis un moment fort toutes les
deux mercredi le lendemain Patrice del
laavau fait trembler les bares mais
boucle tout de même un parcours sans
faute qui permet à la France de rester
dans la course par
équipe j'ai eu beaucoup de chance j'ai
fait j'ai fait une petite erreur en fin
de parcours ce qui a faillli nous coûter
très très cher j'ai eu beaucoup de
beaucoup de chance euh c'est
sûr après le podium par équipe
l'américaine bzy Madden est Cortez C son
cheval de 12 ans sont en tête du
classement individuel mais l'ensemble
des bons parcours réalisés depuis le
début de la semaine permet aux quatre
cavalier tricolor de participer à
l'ultime épreuve qualificative pour la
fameuse finale à 4 quatre Français
encore dans la course pour le titre de
champion du monde il n'est pas interdit
de
rêver mais ça va être dur quand même les
30 meilleurs cavaliers mondiaux sont sur
la piste cet après-midi il en restera
donc plus que quatre Corin ce soir pour
la finale à 4 demain voilà et c'est une
une épreuve très spécifique elle
n'existe qu'au Jeux mondiaux il s'agit
donc pour chaque cavalier qualifié de
monter son propre cheval et les trois
autres chevaux des d'autres concurrents
c'est une formule aussi on en reparlera
très controversée parce que elle impose
de la supplémentaire aux chevaux
certains cavaliers ne souhaitent pas
prêter leur leurs chevaux et puis c'est
une formule qui privilégie je dirais le
pilotage du cheval c'est-à-dire le
cavalier au détriment du couple et ben
on en débattra demain dans notre
émission àid45 avec nav Pierre Durand
donc au tableau des médailles sachez que
la France est remonté grâce à vous à la
6e place avec C médailles dont une en or
TR en Argent Une en bronze on va prendre
la température au village des jeux avec
lou Janner qui est en compagnie d'hélè
Richard qui est en train de nous
concocter la cérémonie de clôture
absolument Émilie bonjour à tous hélè
Richard bonjour bonjour alors cette
cérémonie à la fois d'ouverture et de
clôture c'est important c'est important
c'est un immense honneur que d'être que
d'être là aujourd'hui pour clore 15
jours de grandes compétitions de grandes
fêtes à quelle heure demain alors demain
c'est au stade d'Ornano et c'est entre
17h et 17h30 parce qu'on neit jamais
avec le sport les deux mots importants
sont alors alors pour moi les deux mots
importants c'est faire la fête d'être
festif parce que on clot 15 jours
merveilleux de de grandes de de de
grande compétition et puis le relais le
passage de relais avec nos amis du
Canada pendant 4 ans rendez-vous dans 4
ans et un cadeau et en attendant un
cadeau voilà alors présentez-moi ce
cadeau dites alors ce cadeau c'est donc
les comme vous pouvez voir ce sont de
drôles de chevaux qui sont des sauteurs
alors on est pour la cérémonie de
clôture et bien c'est la finale à Cat
une grande cérémonie de une grande
édition de saut et donc on va la
compléter on va compléter cette comment
dire on va compléter cette cette finale
à finale Matthéo venez nous rejoindre on
va conclure la la finale à 4 avec nos
propres champions des vrais
chevaux des Caval oui mais aussi des
sportifs de haut niveau des athlètes
alètes ça surprend les gens énormément
prend beaucoup de plaisir et le c'est
devenir Dr dites au revoir alors merci
Richard allez au revoir
merci merci beau Jean-Loup la fête
demain donc au stade d'Ornano ces
jeuxqua sont aussi une magnifique
vitrine pour la filière équestre et on
va en parler tout de suite avec Laurence
Monier la présidente d'ipolia oui
hipolia le pôle de compétitivité de la
filière Reekin le seul en France dédié à
l'univers sportif la filière Ikin
représente 180000 emplois en France pour
un chiffre d'affair global de 14
milliards d'euros et depuis 2007 le poul
ipolia a soutenu une centaine de projets
a permis la création de é on va
s'arrêter là la liste est longue
Laurence meunier dites-moi les jeux se
terminent vous qu'est-ce que vous avez
ressenti au niveau de la filière est-ce
que vous avez vu vraiment que des des
liens se tissaient que vraiment ces gens
on vraiment servi de vitrine écoutez moi
je suis aujourd'hui absolument sidéré de
voir l'engouement qu'a suscité ou
consuscité les deux stands ippolia qui
représentent d'un côté l'innovation et
de l'autre côté la recherche parce qu'il
faut savoir que nos chevaux aussi
fantastiques soi-ils et et nos nos
cavaliers également s'il y a pas
derrière des matériels et des
technologies de pointe pour leur
permettre d'atteindre le meilleur et si
on n' pas non plus des des chercheurs
qui recherchent très très
fondamentalement sur la santé de nos
chevau et bien on narriverait pas à ses
performances donc on œuvre pour le
bien-être la performance la santé du
cheval à travers la Fondation ipolia la
recherchéinnovation vous soutenez de
nombreux projets on va voir quelques
images pendant qu'on parle de la société
chevalete par exemple c'était pour
sont dans l'Orne jument bio voilà c'est
un procédé unique
euh ex combien combien vous avez investi
par exemple pour aider cette cette
société honnêtement je suis incapable de
vous dire j'ai pas les 100 projet en
tête c'est 65 millions d'euros
globalement depuis la création du pôle
de compétitivité qui ont soutenu ces
projets et mais pourquoi on soutient ce
genre de projet qu'est-ce qui vous
motive alors il y a un comité d'experts
extrêmement indépendant très transversal
sur toutes les disciplines qui a aimé un
avis et qui attribue ou pas label et
après les financements suivent ou pas en
fonction de la pertinence des projets
alors vous disiez vous soutenez aussi he
la la recherche expliquez-nous un peu ce
ce volet de votre action on a créé une
fondation on a d'un côté un pôle de
compétitivité qui permet comme vous
l'avez dit de développer des projets
innovants dans la filière pour les
entreprises de la filière et à côté nous
avons créé une fondation de coopération
scientifique pour soutenir tous les
chercheurs et j'en profite pour faire un
appel au don parce que cette fondation
nous c'est pas dans notre culture
française les anglosaxons sont très
sensibilisés à ça donc il faut qu'on
soutienne les fonds publics se RAR même
si on est très aidé par les
collectivités par l'État il faut pour
soigner nos chevaux pour les aider pour
leur bien-être et pour leur
performance un exemple pendant que vous
parlez on voit des image du CAL le
centre d'imagerie de recherche sur les
affections locomotrices et Kin
concrètement qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
dans ce centre dans ce centre c'est le
centre qui est leader au monde sur les
sur la locomotion sur l'imagerie euh les
pathologies de locomotrice du cheval on
est on a des des des matériels
absolument extraordinaires IRM
satigraphie enfin c'est comme un CHU
c'est l'umaine mise à la disposition du
cheval et ces jeux ont permis de donner
un coup de projecteur sur toutes ces
activités merci beaucoup Laurence Meier
d'avoir accepté notreation vous je le
merci Laurence vous êtes bien entouré
heinticip j'attendais mon massage Corine
on fait un tour peut-être rapidement sur
le marathon va voir ce qui se passe du
côté de l'hippodrome DEC une bonne
nouvelle figurez-vous que ce sont trois
Français maintenant qui occupe la tête
de ce marathon toujours Sébastien
mourien en tête suivi par
notre ami thbao coudri du Berry et c'est
intercalé en 3e position Sébastien
Vincent comment ça se passe le compte
des points ça se cumule avec le dressage
che indépendant comment est-ce qu'on
comment ça marche alors les points se
cumulent effectivement avec ceux du
dressage et se cumuleront effectivement
avec la de la dernière épreuve celle de
maniabilité et bien je vous invite à
suivre le marathon sur notre site
internet
bastirnormandie.france3.fr nous Anthony
on se retrouve demain à 12h45 pour une
émission spéciale avant la finale A4
avec Éric navé et Pierre Durand entre
autres encore très bien entouré demain
encore très bien entouré merci à tous et
encore bravo pour ces trois médailles
apportées à la France grâce à vous les
vol merci beaucoup très bon après-midi
et à demain 1245 et 15h onement fort sur
France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]